what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today there is a lot of Deadpool 3
news that I am really excited to talk
about a lot of people are super excited
for Deadpool 3 Deadpool is finally going
to be in the MCU we know it's going to
be an action-packed fun and funny movie
and Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios has confirmed recently that yes
it is going to be rated R so this is
going to be the typical Deadpool that we
know and love however he is now playing
in the sandbox that is the MCU so he'll
be able to interact with all of the
characters that we know and love and
what's really great about Deadpool 3 is
that he's going to be interacting with
both universes from Marvel the fox
universe and the MCU and it's looking
like Deadpool 3 is actually going to be
a lot more important than we thought it
would be this movie is shaping up to be
more than just a joyride between buddies
Deadpool and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in
which that alone would have been enough
to make an Epic movie Hugh Jackman
returning as Wolverine interacting with
Ryan reynolds's Deadpool would have been
enough alone to probably make this one
of the biggest Marvel movies ever but to
add on top of it they are bringing more
actors back and they're having Deadpool
3 be a pretty important movie moving
forward to the Multiverse Saga storyline
recently it has been reported by the rap
that Deadpool 3 is actually going to be
the last movie of phase 5. leading us
right into phase six which is when the
Multiverse is truly going to start
falling apart and it looks like Deadpool
is going to play a big role in why it's
falling apart he won't be the sole
reason but he is definitely going to be
a contributor now bringing back Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine might cause an
incursion or two but also some other
characters that are known and loved are
coming back and it looks like the actors
who play those characters are seemingly
confirming that they are indeed
returning so of course we're going to
break that down but the great news is
that they aren't just returning for
Deadpool 3 but also four secret Wars as
well now some really great and
refreshing news to start off with is
that it looks like despite all of the
recent talk about delays coming from
Marvel Studios it looks like Deadpool
might actually be moved up we've had a
recent report from The Insider account
film Odyssey stating that the film might
be moved up and the other day we got a
report from The Hollywood Reporter
stating that Deadpool 3 is going to
begin filming this spring in London so
it looks like things are about to get
underway with Deadpool 3 and we
shouldn't be expecting any delays now
Deadpool 3 was originally supposed to be
in phase six of the MCU but according to
the rap like I mentioned they say it
will end Phase 5 and right now Deadpool
3 is currently set to release on
November 8th of 2024. so great news
there it doesn't look like Deadpool 3 is
going to be getting delayed and it looks
like there's a pretty good reason for
that we know Deadpool is going to play a
big role in the MCU bringing in a lot of
multiversal aspects to the MCU like we
have never seen seen before it looks
like Deadpool might be causing a lot of
incursions and this movie is going to
lead right up to the Avengers the Kang
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars and
there's something that you need to know
about these two Avengers movies that are
very important based off of what we know
about these two movies there's going to
be a big difference between the two of
them and that is mainly revolved around
the Multiverse the Kang Dynasty won't be
so much about the Multiverse but at the
end it's truly going to open it up and
show us that there are many different
King variants and that Kang can truly
travel the Multiverse then in Avengers
Secret Wars that's when everything is
pretty much going to go down in the
Multiverse and we're going to see a lot
of different teams not just in our
universe but in other universes as well
but we know we're going to have
multiversal Adventures before then and
it looks like Deadpool is going to be
our first true adventure Deadpool is
going to be traveling through the
Multiverse going to many different
universes and bringing these characters
to the MCU and two of these characters
are going to be Patrick Stewart's Prof
Professor Xavier and Ian McKellen's
Magneto now there's been rumors about
this for a while and of course Patrick
Stewart recently reprized his role as
Professor Xavier and Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness but Patrick
Stewart has recently come out and talked
about his return and the return of Ian
McKellen in a recent interview for Star
Trek card with E.T Patrick Stewart
talked a little bit about Charles Xavier
he said Charles Xavier well I am looking
to borrow his wheelchair if we're to do
much more Star Trek or standing up is
becoming a bit of a problem and Patrick
Stewart right now is 82 years old but he
continues to say I can't say about what
Charles's future might possibly hold
teasing them just a little bit but when
asked about what sir Ian McKellen
thought about Patrick Stewart reprising
his role as Professor Xavier in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
this is what he had to say actually it
went very well he did say something like
hey I would have done this you yes
that's true but we're not done sir Ian
and myself we're and then he paused for
a second and then he said we got plans
so Patrick Stewart is severely hinting
that him and Sir Ian McKellen are going
to be returning to reprise their roles
as Professor X and Magneto now this is
coming right after we got all these
reports from the Insiders stating that
they are going to be returning in
Deadpool 3 and then again in secret Wars
in fact when Patrick Stewart said this
in the interview of course everybody
started reporting that he was hinting at
returning and replying to a tweet by the
direct stating that Patrick Stewart has
teased Ian McKellen's return as Magneto
The Insider account my time to shine
hello tweeted Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars
and my time to shine hello has an
incredible track record when it comes to
Scoops so it does look like they are
returning for Deadpool 3 which means
that somewhere along the way in Deadpool
and Wolverine's Journey they're going to
visit a universe of their fellow X-Men
well Wolverine's fellow X-Men this is no
doubt going to be amazing but this is
also no doubt going to cause some
incursions probably Deadpool going
around and going into other different
universes dragging characters out of
those universes bringing them into other
universes well that's what causes
incursions especially if you take two
very powerful and influential people
from universes like Magneto and
Professor Xavier if you take Professor
Xavier out of one Universe you are
taking away the leader of the X-Men plus
not to mention one of the main people
who stops Magneto then again if you take
Magneto out of the universe that is
drastically going to change it as well
but if they are taken from the same
universe then all of a sudden the leader
of the X-Men and the leader of the
Brotherhood of mutants are both gone and
who knows what the other members of
their teams will do once they're gone
now right now we're not entirely sure
how Deadpool is going to get all of
these different characters into the MCU
or if they are even actually going to
end up in the MCU at the the end of
Deadpool 3. since they're going to be in
secret Wars that doesn't necessarily
mean that they'll end up in the main
Universe in the MCU they could be
visiting other universes and that's
where we could see them again it is also
worth noting that it has been rumored
that Hugh Jackman of course will also be
in secret Wars so either Deadpool is
going to throw them all in a car or a
time travel device and put them all in
the MCU or we're going to revisit the
universes that Deadpool might have
broken in Avengers Secret Wars but like
I mentioned the Kang Dynasty at the end
of it is pretty much going to be king
winning The Avengers will most likely
realize that Kang isn't just one single
villain to defeat they have to defeat
him in many different universes that's
what secret Wars is going to be about
but in between the two films it looks
like the Avengers and the other heroes
are going to have to put together a
multiversal team and this could be where
all of these other characters that
Deadpool is going to interact with come
into play Deadpool will be in the MCU
and he could tell the other Heroes hey I
know some other Heroes who could join
the fight I also know some villains who
might want to join the fight as well
because villains do want to beat the
good guys but villains also want to beat
other villains because they want to be
in control and not have somebody else in
control however it happens the future is
super exciting and Deadpool 3 is going
to be a very important and super fun
movie so go ahead and let me know all of
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below and of course if you have any
theories put those in the comments as
well please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest MCU news for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof